ja das hier ist das nh hotel ein
designer hotel mitten in berlin direkt
neben universe mtv also da wo der papst
box und wo auch joko und klaas zu hause
sind die interview ich gleich und ich
kann euch versprechen wenn es um secret
talent den großen wettbewerb auf youtube
geht dann wird es spannend weil der ein
oder andere wird erzählen von den beiden
welches geheime talent er hat außerdem
sprechen wir über mtv home und mit
welcher wehmut sie es verabschieden oder
auch nicht und was sie stattdessen auch
mal skurriles machen würden also bleibt
dran es wird spannend wir wollen jetzt
nicht ein pingpong sofort ok herzlich
willkommen diesen wunderbaren hotel ja
wie ist die lage ja alles gut danke
schön herzlichen dank gut und wir bei
dir wie es bei mir grad aber ich trauere
ja das würde ich euch unterstellen nicht
meinem alten format nach oder tut er das
nicht
mtv hat in einem alten formaten
mainformat gibt es das ist jetzt anders
wir haben ja klar also wie man halt so
trauert also mit mit der nötigen
schwarzen wände mit der nötigen portion
wehmut schaut man darauf zurück aber ist
ja nicht alle tage abend und
dementsprechend schauen wir nach vorne
und was man da so sieht es auch
entspannt und deswegen haben wir diese
sendung abgeschlossene unbeschädigt in
den schrank gestellt und als so viel
trauer ist so ein bisschen härter oder
weicher man erinnert sich an die schönen
dinge und da gab es viele schöne momente
die man da im herzen trägt jetzt diverse
neue projekte und ihr taucht plötzlich
auf youtube auf ersten dinge haben wir
vorher nie gemacht da macht man morgens
in rechner am heck startseite secret
talent das man diesen eigenen youtube
projekt genauer secret talents
entspricht es an
ich war nicht auf die frage sondern ist
eine
aktion die nicht ganz so neu ist sondern
die schon mittlerweile seit einigen
jahren bewährt bei youtube gibt herr und
es ist eher eine ein casting das
veranstaltet wird auf etwas unübliche
art und weise leute können also ihre
talente was auch immer das ist
mannigfaltig hochladen mit einem video
sich bewerben um diesen platz in der
großen show die am 9 juni stattfinden
wird in köln und dann können dann
wiederum die user von youtube dieser
angemeldet sind wählen wen sie denn am
besten finden und einer wird dann das
youtube secret talent 2011 wir ja
moderieren das ganze sind mit dabei die
jury ist natürlich zusammengesetzt aus
den menschen die das anschauen was
einige sind und das ist sehr keine keine
klassische castingshow in dem sinne und
da geht es auch nicht darum dass man
möglichst bescheuerte zurückgebliebenen
leute findet wie in vielen anderen
castingshows dass er so üblich ist
sondern leute die wirklich was können
und da gibt's auch nicht nur singen
sondern wirklich um 1 3 360 grad halle
so jugend winterscheidt wir machen spaß
und action künstler joko winterscheidt
stars ich glaube das ist wichtiger dass
man wirklich das potential hat egal wer
man ist was man kann was man nicht kann
dass das talent hat sich nicht von einem
selbst zu bewerten ist sondern draußen
wurde bewertet wird und dass man ja auch
häufig leute die haben sagen du kannst
nichts aber unter anderen die leute gar
keine ahnung haben man dennoch die
möglichkeit hat das zu präsentieren und
man eigentlich wenn man genug leute
bekommt die gelinge hat es da zu hören
okay auch mit einer etwas seltsam
fähigkeiten kann das ja also ich meine
klasse kann auch seltsame dinge mit mit
seiner hand wo ich sage wie ich glaube
wenn du mitmachen würde es also wenn du
jetzt schon klar wer ist herr das
jugendmobil hättest du auf jeden fall
die gelegenheit dazu kommen dass jetzt
ein talent ist aber es ist dennoch nicht
gestand karrieremäßig absolut nicht ist
und deswegen ist das drin sein
wie viele türme deswegen gespräche das
immer wieder gerne an weil ich das auch
einmal möchte dass du das zeigen kannst
weil viele leute draußen haben das
vielleicht auch so was kann ich da
mitmachen und merken sie einfach so
nicht aber klar es kann so auch noch mal
da kann sich jeder bis zum 8 mai
bewerben mit einem video und es ist ja
eigentlich egal was eure talente es ist
ja also wenn man hat alle freiheiten
dieser welt also die grenzen setzt man
dann setzt man selber moderieren tackern
töpfer frisieren versiegen quasi
frisieren kann man auch machen
frittieren vielleicht die leute alles
wirklich an alles kann nichts muss
wobei ich das video bei youtube de
florieren das vielleicht nicht das ist
widerspricht glaube ich den community
richtlinien ist das wechseln von
irgendwelcher ist nicht so ganz gern
gesehen wird
wobei das witzige ist ja bei youtube
kommen ja auch leute auch mal auch da
denkt man sich so ist das jetzt ein
talent oder ist auch kein talent
ich sag mal war auch bräuchen dass er
nur money boy und bei uns war auch was
denkt ihr über solche leute die ich
meine er winkt schief und krumm wird wie
talent ist es mit der kunst talent ist
das was wir dazu erklärt und ich glaube
dass und das ist kein nein aber das beim
anbau ist es ja immer die große frage in
youtube phänomen und was uns immer
gefragt wird weil wir ihnen ja nun mal
getroffen haben aber gesagt haben der
junge muss bei uns auftreten weil das
wieder wächst zusammen was
zusammengehört mtv hob und money boy und
die erste frage die aber immer gestellt
wird ist er wirklich so und oder ist das
ein genialer schauspieler der frei nach
kind gesagt ich spiele das ich bin das
und perfekt 1 1 in persona tor eines
wiener rappers der immer so leicht neben
dem takt erzählt dass er morgens aus dem
bett aufstehen und wir müssen sagen
entweder zieht das durch alexander
masters sich alles auch hinter der
kamera genauso oder es tatsächlich echt
ich würde diese frage um das mysterium
money boy zu erhalten nicht beantworten
wollen
ich glaube schon dass echt ist weil er
hätte zum beispiel ist eine private
kamera dabei und hat er hat dann also
das ist schon so durchdacht das ist doch
alles enden ja aber das wäre möglich
also man hat sich mit ihm unterhalten
und dann merkt man ja schon so dass wir
schon sehr komplex was er sich da so das
aber wirklich werden wenn du die mädels
gesehen hätten wenn du die mädels
gesehen hat ist wieder vor seine 486
rechner saßen in der flasche wird nico
die noch verschlossen war und wieder
poser fotos gemacht hast das ist mir
schon zu das ist so
das glaube ich nicht also nein mein glas
ich bitte dich das ist nicht das glauben
und land das spaltet die nation ich habe
auch letztlich einen kollegen getroffen
also nahe dass der journalist der macht
das alles als geplant das ist alles ich
finde auch so das ministerium gar nicht
gelöst werden sollte ich finde das ist
einfach da ist macht schon viel schöner
also dass dieser typ einfach der ist wer
ist da macht es einfach einzigartig also
das scheißegal ob das ist man
konstruiert ist oder nicht mein
lieblings kommentar unter dem money boy
video ist sogar die noten stehen sich
bringt ja auch ein punkt oder mit mit
dem ernährung tollen satz dem deutschen
wort beigetragen haben also noch woher
das war mir vorher nicht so klar dass in
euro wichtig ist wenn man unter männern
liebe gesteht das darf auch mal
missverständnisse entstehen können die
man gar nicht beabsichtigt so endlich
ganz den rücken eincremen aber humor
das ist einfach so wieland ist allein
das ist einfach so da da hat man ihm
auch gesellschaftlich einiges zu
beigetragen dass die freundschaften
nicht kaputtgehen zu kommen das hat eine
kleine homo einfach so
klar man ihn umarmen wir hatten letztes
wochenende hatte ich eine youtube partie
und mich hat ein typ so dermaßen angetan
aber was hatte youtube haben der mann
sei angefahren und dann in dieser er
habe ich keinen bock zu und er weiß ich
bin schwul das ist mir egal aber das ist
auch offensichtlich hat sich das
geändert männer umarmen sich und lieben
sich tanzen sich hand und das
preisniveau wie taxi vom ja aber die
dinge würde ich mal nachdenken doch
nicht so zeigen damit sie können gerne
das ist doch keine kugel solche leute
wie man die wollen gab es die vorher
nicht oder sind die woanders auch die
hatten keine plattform
ich glaube die aktion also so und
irgendwie in einer klasse oder so hatten
wir auch mal eine sky der hat der war
sehr davon überzeugt dass er ein sehr
guter stuntman ist und hat sich dann
immer so stein treppen runter gestürzt
aber natürlich echt ja er hat einfach
den schmerz nicht zeigen wollen hat dann
gesagt nicht es war alles schon
ich habe mich nicht wirklich verletzt
ich bin so gut dass dann wenn das halt
so aussieht als wäre gerade wirklich die
18 meter große stein treppe
runtergefallen und wir haben halt auch
immer bevor er dann gesagt mensch du
bist ein wahnsinn stuntman machen
nochmal und so und das ist ein solcher
ist das heute sich nicht verändert würde
würde ich jetzt nicht mehr machen kann
heute bei ist busfahrer tätig und schöne
grüße an dieser stelle aber erlebten
auch ja
also die hatten keine plattform die sind
jetzt hat sie an der formal gar nicht
gegeben dass man sich so präsentieren
konnte und weil ich der breiten masse
also du kannst ja tatsächlich auch
regional übergreifend also sind wir
deutschland und kann sehr international
quasi wenn es jetzt mal ohne verbalen
inhalt ist kannst du ja erfolg teilhaben
also dieses böse gucken die baby war es
nämlich keine ahnung ich will mich auch
mal glück wurde da wird da ist kein satz
drin wichtig ist aber dieses baby wird
nichts davon haben außer dass ich wieder
sagen kann ich mal auf youtube
aber es hat einfach so die möglichkeit
dass ins netz zu stellen und die ganze
welt ganz angucken das gab's wohin man
kann ja geld verdienen der junge hier
der vom zahnarzt kam als absolventen
haben die schon 100.000 damit verdient
weil t shirts und so weiter
partnerprogramm auf youtube klar wenn
man das schloss und das für sich nutzen
wir sind für sich zu nutzen weist auf
die sich ja so dass dann irgendwelche
leute der bekannt werden die davon von
ihrem glück sagen mal selber oft nichts
wissen weil sie irgendwie mikrofon
verschlucken versehentlich oder roller
oder andere kleine harmonisiert werden
dadurch dass etwas rein gestellt wird
aber klar wenn man wenn man sich bewusst
darüber ist aber interessant finde ich
ja wenn man merkt dass die leute
probieren ein video zu lancieren was
nicht echt ist also wenn dann allgemeine
situation gestellt wird in der hoffnung
darauf dass ich das dann andere leute
anschauen also da scheint es dann doch
ein ganz gutes bauchgefühl zu geben bei
der community um rauszufinden was ist
wirklich echt aber das authentisch und
was wir jetzt gerade mal eben für diesen
kurzen dreh den wir hier machen so
hingestellt
das läuft dann auch nicht und das finde
ich ganz so dass sich das so eine ganz
natürlich reguliert eine lehrerin ist
empfindlich weil beim fernsehen werde
gesagt wenn ich das richtig gut machen
wird dass keiner sehen aber die leute
sehen ist also im netz wenig zeigt sich
dass die leute ein absolut sicheres
gefühl dafür haben was in
anführungszeichen eben authentisch ist
und was nicht authentisch ist wird es
auch qualitativ
mittlerweile total live im fernsehen
durch kameras eine ehe genau so wollen
wir darüber einfach kein unterschied
mehr sieht es im bild ob es tatsächlich
fürs netz produziert wurde das ganze
produziert wurde inzwischen mit jeder
kamera magath
wie ist das denn bei euch damit wie seid
ihr denn zu mtv gekommen war das richtig
so professionell casting und man wird
getestet und wenn man das vernünftig
macht dann kommt man erst rein oder ist
dass ich habe lange vorher als redakteur
gearbeitet habe dann markus kavka auf
einer produktion kennengelernt haben
wert darauf gelegt auf der party wo ich
quasi arbeiten musste bei zwei drei bier
ihm erzählt dass ich ganz gerne das mal
ausprobieren würde und hatte aber auch
eine ganze sonore stimme selber weil ich
ein bisschen was getrunken hatte habe
ich jetzt auch ja ich habe auch ein
bisschen was getrunken deswegen ja nicht
an einer tankstelle geholt arbeiten ich
trinke ich arbeite aber dann war es
einfach so dass ein bisschen zeit vor
gegen markus sie sich dann gemeldet hat
und das war so eine kleine
eigeninitiative und david das glück das
man halt in kontakt kam mit markus er
damals als casting zuständig war und
dann ist man den ganz normalen weg
gegangen hat wahrscheinlich so viele wie
im richtigen cars ebenfalls eine kleine
runde war aber hat sich dann da
durchgesetzt und eine chance bekommen
und dass ich das gemacht hat sich auch
wieder mal so ein bisschen das risiko
bei mtv
wenn man guckt was ist aus denen die das
vorher gemacht haben geworden
die wenigsten sind irgendwie mit dem
publikum gewachsen sondern die sind
einfach nicht mehr musikfernsehen auch
new york us schauspieler
andere aussagen das gibt einem acker
zwischen in schwarz oder gefangen mit
steht angefangen mit unter ulmen damals
gerade die frühe anfangszeit als mtv
glaube ich nach berlin kam da ging es
los mit den un
diese handlung ich glaube sein erster
richtiger großer film war herr lehmann
und das war ja lange nachdem er bei mtv
eigentlich schon bekannt war und dort
einer der ersten menschen war also dass
diese generation irgendwann nicht mehr
da sein wird und so das liegt einfach an
dem wandel der dinge das liegt daran
dass wir jetzt gerade hier nicht bei mtv
von der kamera sitzen sondern bei
youtube und das hat er alles in grund
und das kann man daraus kann man auch so
die veränderung der mediennutzung
ableiten und ist ja auch total richtig
dass sich sowohl die neue generation an
zuschauern an popkultur konsumenten wenn
man so will bildet die natürlich auch
andere wege finden weil es mittlerweile
andere möglichkeiten gibt dann so und
das letztendlich ist auch dafür
verantwortlich das ist musik fernsehen
so wie vor zehn jahren nie wieder geben
wird und dann muss man auch nicht das
tages- oder traurig sein sondern man
muss selber so offen sein um zu schauen
was jetzt gerade los ist und was es
jetzt mehr möglichkeiten gibt und wenn
wir dann wenn wir jetzt schon betrauert
das ist diese plattform musikfernsehen
für junge moderatorin vielleicht nicht
mehr gibt vor ein paar minuten haben
noch darüber gesprochen was für eine
große internationale bühne vielleicht
sogar man durch kleine internetfilmchen
haben kann und durch seine eigene
sendung die man als mit einem kumpel
zusammen erstellt wenn man sich ein
bisschen mehr ein fuchs haben kann und
genau das gab es dann halt vor zehn
jahren nicht und ich denke so
löst eine das andere ab und man muss man
wissen wie man damit umgeht die
wahrnehmung ist auch nur von unserer
seite so dass dieses nachwuchs modul mtv
da existent gewesen ist wie das noch so
kennen also für die jetzt damit auf
wachsenden ist mtv
die werden vielleicht als mtv hoben die
ich noch mal auf worden seien oder
gucken sich der comics an
für diese sind ganz andere sender also
wir haben eine ganz andere bindung zu
diesem sender modell was es da mal
gegeben hat als die jetzt damit auf
wachsenden quasi so wie unser einer
vielleicht hier und da noch mal an demag
umrechnet und wie dies heute den euro
als wahrscheinlich da also bei großen
beträgen muss ich mal wieder sagen sie
machen das ist ganz einfach wirklich so
dass ich das immer wieder einmal ein
klassisches beispiel dafür findet wie
sich dinge verändern einfach also das
ist klar ist es jetzt kann man darüber
reden aber es ist für die die jetzt hier
genauer gesagt habe sich das angucken
die gucken sich hier nicht mehr im tv
oder das für die das gelernte - trotzdem
diese gibt es bei euch nicht die
befürchtung irgendwann mal in
anführungszeichen weg vom fenster zu
sein im wie halt viele andere ich immer
weil man hat ja keine besondere
fähigkeit sag ich jetzt mal auch für uns
alle drei priester sogar noch gesagt sie
wollen ja man kann reden und aber wie
man redet mit wem man redet das und über
was man redet das kann in dem moment
kannst super spielst du ja absolut und
dazu verfolgen recht wir haben überhaupt
keine besondere fähigkeit ich habe
permanent das gefühl dass irgendwann
jemand bei mir an die tür klopft mich
erwischt und sagt so mein freund ist es
genug jetzt gehst du arbeiten und dieses
gefühl das ich bislang noch nicht
erwischt wurde
das beschleicht mich immer mal wieder
und
das fast eigentlich ganz gut zusammen
das was du gerade gesagt dass wir haben
keine also deswegen finde ich es umso
besser dass wir die secret talents unser
unser tablet ist so gut dass da wirklich
wir haben selber nicht mehr gefunden
wird fasst bringen können wir hätten
keinen und auch da wieder ein money boy
mäßiges mysterium das lösen wir jetzt
nicht auf haben wir das oder haben wir
nicht vielleicht vielleicht ja
vielleicht ja aber gerade im fernsehen
ist man ja von etwas abhängig von dem
man den youtube nicht so abhängig ist
weil im youtube entscheidungs publikum
im fernsehen kann es aber sein dass
irgendwelche nasen sagen die beiden
kommen ich hab es kann sich niemand
sehen will das stimmt aber doch auch
nicht noch nicht
also das ist ja was die klickzahlen im
internet sind sind letztendlich die
quoten im fernsehen und ich glaube auch
nicht dass jemand dort selbst weiß nicht
20 jahren der sendung macht und jeder
einzelne aus dem vorstand wie den total
sympathisch findet aber wenn er halt
jede woche zehn millionen ein pferd aber
ja gut kann ja sein aber es muss endlich
umgesetzt werden acht neue sendung es
kann ja sein wenn alle flops liegt nicht
an euch sondern das konzept und sonnig
treffen wir bei uns im internet
aber das kann ja sein man hat das ja
nicht komplett im griff
ja weil wir das schon es ist auch diese
partie aber damit kommt es auf die
hartz4 ist auch die erste das ist ja
etwas provokant natürlich reden aber nee
das ist glaube ich auch so eine sache
die man sich die man sich mal bewusst
machen muss zum einen lässt du dich mit
diesem job
und wenn du sänger bist oder ich weiß
dass ich oder wenn du irgendwie bilder
malz und lässt du dich darauf ein dass
irgendwann keiner mehr kommt und sagt
das ist schön
und genauso ist es so dass ich nicht
alle von der abwenden können und sagen
das interessiert mich nicht dass sich
langweilig und so muss man etwas dafür
tun dass das nicht so ist und sich dann
vielleicht auch hier und da noch mal neu
erfinden was letztendlich auch mit der
jeweilige sendung zu tun hat die man
macht und so und wenn es irgendwann
alles wurscht ist und man das so runter
moderiert dann klar merkt das auch
irgendwann einer dass das berühmte
bauchgefühl von dem iran gesprochen habe
ich glaube dass jetzt dann auch ein
aber was noch glaube ich viel
entspannter ist es so dass was ist das
schlimmste was passieren kann bis dahin
nicht mehr im fernsehen aber ich glaube
nicht dass man sich so persönlich nur
darüber definiert also wenn man dann
wenn dann nicht wenn es keine
vielleicht tatsächlich mein mann hat
eben eine zeit in der man keine
besonderen ideen hat und es kommt auch
niemand mit einer guten idee auf dich zu
nadal erstmals halt also ich finde das
jetzt nicht das allerschlimmste im
fernsehen zu arbeiten und irgendeinen
job zu machen nämlich interessiert und
so und da gibt es noch genug
möglichkeiten den antrieb der motivation
frage für nicht warum man das macht also
macht man ja wirklich weil es spaß macht
weil es nicht anfängt wie arbeit und ich
sag mal sekundär kommt dann der faktor
dazu das fernsehen ist also das ist das
würde ich auch so um jeden tag machen
wenn er keine kamera läuft habe ich
einfach bock dran und da ist also
natürlich ist der erfolg davon abhängig
ob die leute sehen und damit wiederum
die sicherheit gegeben dass man
vielleicht auch noch andere sachen
machen darf aber es gibt tausend andere
sachen wo man auch sagen würde habe ich
kein problem mit auszuprobieren das zu
machen gemacht na ja und das ist glaube
ich auch sehr erfüllend ist glaube ich
auch so das haptische erlebnis was man
hat mit diesem weichen warmen ton die
sind diese nasse weiß sondern so wie es
daraus formen dass man nur am anfang
dieser klotz seiner hand und auch diese
du machst diese konnte aber auch diese
kognitiven verbinden ein bisschen so
dieses rad schwingen und dann diesen ton
einfach den händen halten und dann mit
den fingern vielleicht noch einen kranz
oben machen und nachher noch mit rein
drücken dass es also eine blütenform
main gibt also dass selbst dem
wunderschönen fotos mit den thunern
brennen später und es darum wechsel auf
die farbe dann selbst wenn die richtigen
ton sorgen hast und du hast ihn eine
studie beweist wenn das da rauskommt das
habe ich gemacht
ich würde es gibt so viele schöne sachen
über die das heißt euch ist bekanntheit
popularität nicht so wichtig ist euch
egal ob er vor 10.000 leuten steht das
ist ein nebeneffekt der so ein bisschen
eintritt und ohne das geht nicht weil
das ist die mechanik also sich zum einen
nur daran zu erfreuen weise oder oder
oder sich auf der anderen seite dafür
zuschieben ist glaube ich beides falsch
weil das ist sind die geister die man
rief und wer sich darüber beschwert dass
das finden finde ich auch völlig falsch
und jeder der sagt das nervt mich dann
soll es dann halt einfach sein lassen
das ist ja kein geburtsfehler dass man
auch einmal bekannter ist als jemand
anders
aber genauso wenig muss man jetzt jeden
morgen aufstehen erst ein fenster raus
gehen und darauf warten dass einer kommt
und foto mit ihm machen will
in beide extreme zu kippen finde ich
absolut in ordnung
absolut genommen es vervollständigt mich
auch ein verdienst den mann damit
popularität ist hat eben was ihr gesagt
habe ich etwas schönes ist aber auch was
unangenehm ist aber es ist ja auch ein
fiasko es kommt drauf an glaube ich für
was du bekannt bist nun also weil
mittlerweile das ist auch wir sind die
pervertierung von bestimmten sendungen
und von bestimmten medien dies halt
möglich machen bekannt zu sein ohne dass
du eigentlich für etwas bekanntes
normalerweise machst du irgendwas das
machst du besser als andere prominenz
gibt es irgendwie auch nicht erst als
fernsehen oder zeitungen gibt
johannes der täufer hat jetzt auch nicht
so viel drauf ja und trotzdem könnten
die leute auf der straße erkannt na ja
nie aber ich glaube dieses dieses wenn
man das wirklich unterbricht auf die
grundfesten warum ist jemand prominent
dann jemand weil weil einer dem anderen
erzählt kommt man der kann das ein
bisschen besser und auf einmal macht das
so ein lauffeuer und derjenige ist dann
wäre und es gibt ja auch einen kleinen
kreis in dem dorf in einer kleineren
stadt in meiner straße und so und das
ein bisschen übertragen aus aus aus
große ganze finde ich insofern okay wenn
jemand bekannt ist weil er etwas besser
kann etwas gut macht für etwas gemacht
wird oder vielleicht auch gehasst wird
aber für eine bestimmte sache
und dann gibt es wiederum dieses andere
klientel was jetzt in den in den letzten
20 jahren privatfernsehen auch so
herangewachsen ist das sind menschen die
einfach erstmal bekannt sind und was sie
letztendlich machen ist eigentlich eine
nebenerscheinung ihrer bekanntheit und
sie müssen irgendwas machen wir
ansonsten braucht man ja nicht filmen
aber was sie machen es eigentlich erst
mal ruhig die sollen schönen dorf oder
schön laut oder schön
peinlich dabei sein und dann geht das
schon aber wenn du wenn du so sind die
motivationslage wieder so also warum
macht macht man es machen möchte oder
macht man halt einfach nur das will und
da ist dann glaube ich ganz schnell auch
klar wo die steuern wo der weizen liegt
und was man sich dann davon ab sondern
und da werden würdet euch würde euch das
töpfern genügen und eine es muss am ende
ein glaube ich einfach erfüllen also es
muss wirklich jeder job also ich kann
auch total glücklich jeden morgen ein
mann für uns ja ja ja und das werden
dann auch die 50 leute die immer wieder
kommen und eure köpfe kaufen oder 5 nur
einer ist oder wenn wenn wenn ein also
dieses produkt von dna enthält und dann
sie zu hause die minuten da rein stellt
einfach so dass das wasser die jugend
auch zum sprießen bringt man dann da
steht und sie so in eine vase hat dieser
blume des lebens einfach verlängert dann
ist es doch genauso schön also wenn ich
sage hier ist osborne gut dann wünsche
ich euch noch viel spaß beim kämpfen
jetzt das jetzt möglich
ihr dürft aber ich habe jetzt nichts
dabei